meetings that of course uh he would
probably have uh
anyway uh these are people many of
them he's known for decades throughout
his time uh and career uh working on
foreign policy issues but
right now he is being set out and the
administration is being shut out of
our intelligence briefings and national
security
provide real-time information uh threat
assessments uh
data about the threats we're facing
around the world our engagements around
the world
and information you need to get the
pandemic under control
on wednesday uh the president-elect met
with front-line workers
hearing first-hand accounts from health
care workers and first responders
who are bearing the high emotional toll
of helping others recover from kovid
and just yesterday the president-elect
and the vice president-elect met with
democratic and republican governors from
the national governors association
in a meeting i should say convened by
the national governors
association and they talked about the
importance of working together as
one country to be coveted uh addressing
covet and getting the pandemic under
control is not
a partisan issue it's not an issue
that's going to be solved by one party
it needs to be
something that's done together with
health experts and scientists and
certainly
leaders from both parties and as you
also may know
uh today the president-elect and vice
president-elect later this afternoon i
should say we'll be meeting we'll host
speaker pelosi and leader schumer for a
meeting in wilmington
they'll discuss emergency aid that
families desperately need
small businesses need and state and
local governments need
uh at this uh critical point in time uh
of course the
president-elect um and he also named
several members of his team
about a little more than a dozen
including uh last week before we spoke
he of course had named his white house
chief of staff and
uh this week including some this morning
we've announced uh
several uh a number of diverse qualified
and experienced
uh individuals who will be filling
important roles in the white house uh
moving forward and as we look ahead to
next week and approach the thanksgiving
holiday
he's going to be focusing on continuing
to
address be briefed on speak out about
the crisis facing our country
we know this isn't a holiday season that
most people
would have been nervous and they will
continue to do the work to ensure that
during next year's holiday uh we can
celebrate with our
loved ones so with that i will turn it
over to johannes
thanks jen and thanks everyone for
making the time to be here
as jen mentioned the gsa administrator
has yet to ascertain
the results of the election despite an
overwhelming consensus
that joe biden is the winner of the
election and therefore the
president-elect
and as jen also mentioned we continue to
move forward in the absence of an
ascertainment decision
however the non-ascertainment does place
limits on the resources available to the
transition and most importantly
our access to federal agencies this
isn't a game
who gets to talk to whom our inability
to start our formal agency review
process has the potential to have real
impacts on families across the country
in fact there is a growing chorus of
national leaders who are calling upon
gsa to move forward with the transition
and sounding the alarm about the
potentially harmful impact of further
delays
earlier this week dr fauci said that the
lack of ascertainment would delay
vaccine distribution leading medical
groups including the american medical
association the american hospital
association
and the american nurses association also
wrote a letter urging the trump
administration to coordinate
with the biden transition on coven 19
planning
public health experts around the country
echoed these sentiments and called for
the gsa to stop delaying ascertainment
and ensure
seamless transition as copit19 infection
rates surged across the country
yesterday numerous business leaders and
groups released statements calling for
the transition process to move forward
including u.s chamber of commerce the
hispanic chamber of commerce the black
chamber of commerce
the business roundtable the national
association of manufacturers
small business for america's future and
other leading business leaders
and finally as jen mentioned this week
the president-elect and the vice
president-elect were briefed by former
national security officials about the
readiness of the diplomatic
defense and intelligence agencies as you
know they are still not able to receive
the critically important
classified briefings that should be
available to them
and so the gsa administrators in action
has the potential to have a real impact
on families across the country now even
in the face of that the transition team
continues to do the work it is able to
including the continued rollout of
senior white house officials
last week we announced during this
briefing that the public jobs portal
would be open on the website
and the personnel team is making strong
progress and getting us ready to hit the
ground on inauguration day with a
diverse
talented team so with that i'd love to
turn it over to uh q
a
great thank you both uh we'll go to lisa
for our first question
with the dejordan great thank you guys
for doing this
i really appreciate it hi guys i've got
um a couple of questions
one if generally you can talk about vice
president-elect harris's role she
mentioned to reporters this week that
she's had a very
um uh tight roll an important role in
the cabinet selections and just anything
more on that would be great
and then also on the covid relief bill
that i know president-elect biden's
talked a lot about
is he lobbying members of congress
directly including today
um republicans and democrats to pass
something
now tell talk us about that and would he
be okay with something less than
what democrat leaders want because he
needs something now
i'll take the i'll take the first
question um
and jen maybe take the second one uh the
answer to the first question is
is easy and so much as vice
president-elect uh harris has been an
integral part of
all personnel discussions uh that
happened during the transition and we'll
continue to play that role
uh i will just uh add still your second
question lisa
uh so as you know uh president-elect
biden and vice president paris will be
meeting with
speaker pelosi and uh schumer
later this afternoon um they are going
to be working in lockstep and they're in
long-step agreement that there needs to
be emergency assistance
and aid before during the lame duck
session to help families to help small
business
there's no more room for delay uh and we
need to move forward as quickly as
possible
he of course is speaking with uh leader
officials or elected officials from uh
both sides of the aisle and we'll
continue to do that but it's an
important meeting this afternoon because
they're going to continue to
work together on pushing that forward
because they know how much that relief
is needed especially as we look
toward the thanksgiving holiday
do you know if he's speaking to
republicans in congress on this
the president wants more uh calls to
read out for you um but he's been doing
a range of calls he has relationships of
course that
go back with people from both sides of
the aisle and if we
bring it out later this afternoon we'll
have to share that with you
well thanks great we'll go to our next
question from eamon jabbers
yeah hey guys thanks for doing this uh i
really appreciate the call so
earlier today a group called demand
progress put out a list of uh democratic
officials and you know veterans of
previous administrations that it said
uh were corporate democrats and too
close to oil and gas and other interests
that they don't like
i'm wondering what effect that list
which includes people like bruce reed
and steve bruchetti
is going to have on your decisions of
how to staff up this white house are you
going to take that
into account in any way or are you going
to ignore it
uh well eamonn thanks for for the
question and as you can see by the
number of announcements that we've
already made to date and the decisions
that have been made by president-elect
biden and vice president
elect harris um they're eager to get uh
their team in place
uh there remains a commitment and we've
certainly seen this as they've had
discussions and made decisions already
and
you'll see this as more names come out
in the weeks to come
that they want the cabinet and also the
white house team and the teams that will
fill these important
roles to look like america and that
means there will be people from
diverse backgrounds experiences
and a diversity of political views
including from
all sides of the democratic party so we
are certainly hearing from and listening
to people and their
thoughts and views um but he's made that
commitment
and i i would encourage people to wait
until we've made
even one announcement about a cabinet
member and certainly more than just a
dozen
white house names before they pass
judgment
the last thing i was discussing is that
you know president-elect
biden is uh he campaigned as somebody
who would be
governing for all of the country that
means democrats that means independence
that means republicans that means
people from all political ideologies
um and his personnel decisions and his
um
you know his approach to how he's going
to fill
those seats and fill the important roles
uh will be reflective of that
um and that's the approach he'll
continue to take and jen thanks
thanks just one quick follow-up
specifically on wall street
uh does the president-elect see a wall
street background
as something that's helpful for
potential white house staffers and
cabinet officials or does you see a wall
street background
background as uh something that's not
great to have on your behalf
well amen i think from having lived
through the um
obama biden uh blissfully lived through
happily lived through the obama biden
administration myself
i i think it's pretty cool to
wall street policies or an advocate for
uh you know a a lot of the policies that
some people would
would be in favor of or be pushing for
from that end his record speaks for
itself and his
um his advocacy and his words speak for
themselves and
his team that he selects will be people
who are
implementing his policies or
implementing the biden agenda there are
people who are committed committed to
putting americans back to work to uh
ensuring there's regulation where there
needs to be
to uh ensuring that people have access
to affordable health care
um those are the the people who will be
named to the cabinet and name to his
team are there to implement
uh his agenda so i would certainly point
people to words he said
uh in his own background over the last
several years
okay thanks guys great we'll take our
next question from sabrina sadiki
thank you both so much for doing this
today i just wanted to
ask if there has been any outreach
to the transition team whatsoever from
current
trump administration officials and if so
what has their message been to the
transition
team and just the second question is
president-elect biden
he said yesterday that he's not ruling
out legal action
can you just talk about at what point
you will feel that all
other options have been exhausted with
respect to the gsa entertainment and
when
it might come to pass that you would
consider legal action
well i'll i'll start and johannes may
have some words of wisdom to add
um so on your second question you know
the president-elect has made clear that
and and and we certainly share this of
course given we all work for him that
our preference would be for the gsa
administrator
to design the ascertainment and we can
all move forward we can have access to
intelligence briefings
uh we can have access to the information
that's necessary to
have our team working on vaccine
distribution
uh have access to the current
information they need we can ensure that
there wouldn't be a delay in americans
getting relief they need come january
20th
that's our preference at the same time i
think there's a shared um
view that or shared running out of
patience happening
um that's happening as you can see on
capitol hill that's happening with
business leaders that's happening with
national security officials
because uh a smooth transition uh and
a a period of transition where the
president-elect the vice president-elect
uh national security officials and
experts experts who are helping us
get the pandemic under control have
access to these things they need
is is essential for our democracy and
for our country
so you know i i would say there's we've
seen that escalate um
externally and and johannes started off
mentioning a couple of the business
leaders and business groups
they want certainty in in the economy uh
they know that if we have a delay in
um in getting the information we need
about vaccine distribution that could
delay that
moving forward we're going the biden
administration is going to be
responsible for the distribution of
the majority of 300 million uh vaccines
if when if that is delayed that could
impact small businesses that could
impact
the economy reopening everybody's
looking for certainty at this point
and the last thing i'll just say is you
know no one no presidential transition
would take
options off the table uh and we
certainly aren't but
we would love it if this afternoon or
even during this call
during this briefing if we learned that
the gsa administrator
signed the entertainment and we could
all move forward with continuing to
prepare to govern
great we'll take oh sorry the only thing
i had added there is we're consulting
with a broad range of stakeholders
outside of the government that
have expertise in various lanes that
will be critical to governing
but at the end of the day exactly as jen
said there's no replacing the real-time
information that can only come from
the post-ascertainment environment that
we should be in right now
in terms of regularized contact and
regular contact with
folks inside the agencies who have
information that would be vital to
everything from our national security to
gen said vaccine distribution
sorry just to be clear you do you have
have you not had any outreach
than trump administration officials so
just sabrina it's a great question and i
know there's been some confusion about
this
we um our teams can't speak with
um or engage with current administration
officials because
um the aspartame that has been delayed
and we would certainly love to have that
engagement and love to be
um discussing with servants and people
who have
been experts on a range of issues from
foreign policy to
health policy um you know preparations
to take over january
but our team has been very careful of
course about following those
rules and guidelines um and we'll have
to abide by that until
uh ascertainment uh happens
great we'll take two more uh we'll move
on to our left side
hi there um yesterday the
president-elect talked a little bit
about his cabinet selections
and i was wondering if you'd be able to
provide kind of a target date for
when you are planning to roll out that
first cabinet nominee
and then also you'll say that every
cabinet position
is important but is there a certain
priority
that you guys have in mind for certain
positions and getting those out first
sure well arla thank you for the
question um so
i've been doing this long enough to know
not to get ahead of the president-elect
um and certainly uh when he's ready to
make his announcements about a cabinet
he'll do that
he indicated yesterday that that will be
around thanksgiving that's aligned with
the timing
uh that uh of the announcement of
cabinet nominees back in 2008 when i was
working on the obama
transition um and i expect you'll hear
more from him on that soon but
since you gave us the opportunity i just
wanted to say one thing about the
cabinet
um and the nominees he is committed to
uh selecting and as he indicated has
selected some people who are
qualified who are experienced who are
going to be prepared on day one
to address the crises that our country
is facing
and he will also put together a team
that looks like america that is diverse
in terms of ideology
uh and background as well so that's how
he's looking at putting together his
team and
we certainly saw today that um there
were a number of republicans who have
indicated they'd be open
to supporting nominees uh that feels
like a positive sign forward because
a positive sign because we know that the
american people are not expecting
obstruction
they're expecting members of both
parties democrats and republicans to
come together and help put
qualified and experienced people in
place to address the various
crises that our country is facing uh and
i expect
um you'll know more soon you'll know
more in the coming weeks
great thanks and we'll take our last
question from sandstein
bye guys uh thanks for doing this much
appreciated um
this is a bit of a weird question but um
obviously as you're planning for the
transition this is happening during
a spike in uh kovid um and there's
articles about the difficulties in
actually
laying out the physical space of the
white house and how to use it
i'm wondering if you can walk us through
what type of
decisions are being made plans are being
implemented to actually
physically staff the premises of the
white house come
january 21st when you expect to be there
so our our top priority as you saw in
the campaign and certainly as you've
seen throughout the transition is
the uh following the science and abiding
uh keeping the safety of our team
um top of mind and it's a dynamic
uh situation with the pandemic but let's
see the exact same
adherence to and commitment to the
science of keeping
the team safe that you saw in the
campaign that you see during the
transition
you'll see that as we enter into the
white house physical space
does that how does that manifest itself
are we talking about fewer people
actually working from the west wing
we don't have anything to share on that
at this moment but i think you can
rest assured that we will follow the
science and we'll put procedures in
place to keep our team safe
and as you can see sam we are obviously
not
not working in a transition office uh
children's art and such things um and
johannes obviously needs more pictures
on as well
but we also president-elect and the vice
president-elect have
conveyed to all of us that we should do
our best to be model citizens as well
which means being safe and i know this
is just about this moment of time
and safe of course wearing masks um you
know where most of us are
of course the vast majority are working
remotely um because
uh you know we want to be models for the
country too
thanks
great well thank you everybody for
joining us um and
we'll have plenty of news in the coming
weeks uh that we'll discuss with all of
you
you